[Music]
on this tuesday night canadians who feel
compelled to help ukraine
it was hard to
to watch it and not do anything about it
the dangerous missions they're taking on
and the horrors discovered in places
where russian forces have withdrawn
manitobans get ready for what's coming
got to prepare for the worst as
forecasters predict the worst blizzard
in decades
the manhunt underway in new york city
after a shooting inside a subway at rush
hour
turbulence for flare airlines
why the low-cost carrier's operating
license is up in the air
and his voice was memorable and
guy unmistakable into a bar
remembering comedian gilbert godfrey
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky is
warning of a new stage of terror in his
country and russia's president says
peace talks have reached a dead end
there was never any peace to keep
vladimir putin's bombardment of ukraine
has now gone on for 48 days one of the
latest claims that has not been verified
is that russian forces used a drone to
drop chemical weapons on the port city
of mariupol which has been under siege
for weeks western officials including
the u.s are investigating but cannot
confirm anything
use of bio or chemical weapons against
the people of ukraine would elicit a
response not just from the united states
but from the international community
what that response would look like um
from us or from anybody else we just
don't know right now
what is becoming clear is the scale of
the killings in areas where russian
forces have now withdrawn ukraine's
president said today there are thousands
and thousands of victims and hundreds of
cases of brutal torture crystal
gomencing has our top story tonight in a
warning it does include graphic images
that are difficult to watch
under the watchful eye of french
forensic experts ukrainians unearthed a
second mouse grave in bucha
when the number of dead got too high it
was important to bury them says this
church leader the church property was
used he says because we couldn't get to
the cemetery they were shooting at cars
more than 400 bodies have been recovered
from around bucha they must be
identified their wounds documented and
re-buried we have now a lot of job
unfortunately with war crimes warm
crimes against humanity
if war crimes have occurred ukraine's
prosecutor general says those
responsible will be held accountable
vladimir putin however called the scene
in bucha fake and used air quotes
when describing russia as the aggressor
at a public display with ally belarus
putin said russia had to defend the
russian speakers of eastern ukraine
many ukrainian cities targeted and
civilians killed in the fighting are
russian-speaking
kramatorsk in the dawn bass home of the
gutted train station mariupol under
siege for weeks in the south
the azov battalion a group founded as a
far right ultra nationalist volunteer
infantry is fighting on the ukrainian
side in mariupol
it posted a video on its telegram
channel late monday showing a number of
soldiers and civilians who appear to be
ill claiming russian forces hit them
with a poisonous or potentially
poisonous substance
that claim has not been verified but
western officials say if it's true it
could change the course of the war the
russians have certainly proven
more than willing to use
chemical weapons when it suited them in
the past use of chemical weapons is
abhorrent it does cross a line the uk
and the u.s are among those working to
determine if a chemical agent was used
but without access to the site it's
difficult to prove
american military intelligence says
control of the critical port city is
contested but ukraine continues to fend
off russian forces for now
crystal gomencing global news london
we know some people have gone to ukraine
from canada and other countries to join
the fight against russian forces
governments including canada's advise
against that but it's happening anyway
others have gone not to fight but to
help to do what they can to get supplies
in and people out our jeff semple
recently returned from ukraine here's
his report on the canadians answering
ukraine's pleas for help canadian lex
brakovsky is embarking on a dangerous
journey packing this van full of
supplies from baby food to body armor
and driving it to the front lines in
ukraine watching it from from my home in
canada was just driving me nuts like it
was hard to uh
to watch it and not do anything about it
six weeks ago brakovsky was here on his
boat in nova scotia the lobster
fisherman moved to canada 30 years ago
but grew up in ukraine within days of
russia's invasion he flew to poland and
met a local aid group looking for
drivers willing to travel to the front
lines they need people that are willing
to go more than they need money i think
because there isn't too many people that
that are
you know ready to to drive to places
like that and for good reason last month
berkovsky delivered aid to this city
near the russian border he then filled
his van with women and children and was
driving them out when his vehicle came
under attack all we've seen is just
explosions right right right in front of
us he and hundreds of others were
trapped he spoke to global news from
their shelter we tried to get out three
times yesterday but every time we get we
get anywheres or
right away under constant shelling
there's absolutely no power no heat
no
very limited water supply finally after
five days of failed attempts he managed
to escape
back to the relative safety of levive in
western ukraine after a few hours of
sleep he headed back to the front lines
with another shipment of aid we need
this help an adviser to the ukrainian
president had this message for other
ukrainian canadians for the many leaders
of the ukrainian diaspora in canada
maybe it's time to come to ukraine
global news met many canadians answering
that call from the ukrainian government
from all walks of life i was actually
in a way pleasantly surprised
that so many canadians have have come
here this canadian ukrainian
entrepreneur is now handling logistics
and procurement for ukraine's volunteer
defense forces this millwright from bc
isn't even ukrainian but he's taking six
weeks unpaid leave to deliver aid and
rescue civilians these people have been
fighting the further democracy and i
just couldn't stand for the russians to
come back and take that all away from
them ottawa is advising canadians to
avoid all travel to ukraine but these
volunteers say staying home wasn't an
option
jeff temple global news toronto
there is a storm brewing over the center
of canada an environment canada is
warning people to take it seriously it's
issued alerts for a large section of
southern saskatchewan manitoba and
ontario manitoba is expected to get up
to 50 centimeters of snow with wind
gusts of up to 90 kilometers an hour
that will create white-out conditions
and make travel dangerous brittany
greenslade reports on how manitobans are
preparing
shopping hearts are piled high as
southern manitobans rush to stock up
ahead of the storm hopefully get things
like milk and fresh fruit and i'll see
what else there is this morning i went
and bought a small propane stove
some store shelves are already bare no
milk eggs or bread left lettuce and
fresh vegetable owls have also been
cleared and many places are out of
bottled water as people stock up basic
groceries that we're going to need just
in case we do get snowed in everybody's
kind of you know trying to you know get
a little ahead of the game
but you know
got to prepare for the worst and to
hunker down at home for the first time
in 25 years school divisions in winnipeg
are considering closing down and getting
ahead of the storm and daycares are
concerned kids may get stranded it's
going to be crazy so
we're definitely keeping an eye on that
i you know i don't want to host a
sleepover for a bunch of preschoolers
without their parents
the impending storm is already drawing
comparisons to a generational spring
blizzard from 25 years ago that saw cars
buried in winnipeg streets and emergency
vehicles stuck the priority is to make
sure that all of our critical services
don't fail if we need to start
stationing snow plows in front of fire
paramedic stations so ambulances and
fire trucks can get out
then that's what we're going to do while
keeping everyone safe ahead of the
holiday weekend brittany greenslade
global news winnipeg
manitobans are used to winter storms
what's in store with this one global
news meteorologist ross hull is tracking
it for us tonight
hi donna well a couple of features that
make this storm stand out the first it's
potency where we've got arctic air
coming up against warm air we've got a
powerful system with heavy amounts of
snow on the way and strong winds the
second factor the longevity this system
will be impacting southern manitoba
southeastern saskatchewan likely into
early friday you can already see the
heavy snow through the dakotas the snow
now starting to cross the international
border as the system heads north we've
got winter storm warnings in winnipeg
blizzard warnings as you head west the
visibility is expected to be near zero
in these areas and heavier amounts of
snow possible as well especially some of
those terrain features like the turtle
mountains and riding mountains let's
take a look at this system it
intensifies as we head into tomorrow
morning you see the tightly packed
isobars representing strong winds those
are areas of equal barometric pressure a
bit of a lull in the precipitation
possible across southeastern portions of
manitoba into wednesday afternoon and
wednesday evening but the system
re-intensifies on thursday how much snow
to expect for winnipeg it looks to be in
that 30 to 50 centimeter range remember
i told you those surface features well
with some enhancement some areas could
see 50 possibly close to 80 centimeters
of snow and of course we don't need that
snow to melt quickly it's the peak of
the spring flood season thankfully it
looks like temperatures will not be
warming up anytime soon at least for the
next few days donna which is some good
news but first we need to get through
all that heavy snow well let's know
global news meteorologist ross hull
thanks
canada's top doctor confirms what's
obvious the country is in the sixth wave
of cobit 19.
it's all across canada doesn't matter
where you are
it's very likely
that omicron variant the ba2 sublineage
is
spreading quite widely in your community
with another holiday weekend approaching
health officials are reminding canadians
indoor gatherings come with risks jamie
morocco reports
maya parikh is done waiting for kovid to
calm down to spend time with her family
over the holidays we feel this is a kind
of a you know pleasure to see them after
a long time
so this is this is kind of a very
important for us
but gathering is not without its risks
according to canada's top health
official doesn't matter where you are in
canada right now i would advise getting
that booster shot
and
masking
and improving ventilation
dr teresa tam stopped short of
recommending provinces bring back
mandates only quebec and pei are keeping
masking measures in place until after
the holidays
on monday philadelphia became the first
major u.s city to bring mandatory
masking back ahead of passover and
easter gatherings i don't see us going
back into any more really very restrict
kinds of restrictions but you always
have to have the flexibility as canada's
numbers for third doses have languished
below 50 for months doctors here hope to
see the federal government recommend a
change to the definition of fully
vaccinated from two doses to three
they're in the hospitals because they're
inadequately protected and we're trying
to at the same time figure out how to
save the hospitalizations and prevent
them from happening and threatening our
health care system and the answer is
right in front of our face
instead the focus remains on encouraging
a third shot the most recent
recommendation is anyone over 18 should
get a booster and 12 to 17 year olds may
six months after their second dose
precautions alan white and his wife
joanne are confident in we're all boxed
and boosted so we should be safe
celebrating but with the expectation
we've learned enough and done enough to
keep ourselves healthy jamie morocco
global news toronto
in the uk prime minister boris johnson
has apologized but is ignoring calls to
resign after being fined for breaching
covet 19 lockdown rules when he attended
a birthday party thrown for him at 10
downing street i myself fell short when
it came to observing the very rules
which the government i lead
had introduced
the country's finance minister was also
fined both are also accused of
misleading parliament a party in june of
2020 happened when the rules banned
indoor gatherings of more than two
people it was one of several parties
held at the time johnson first denied
their dna and later admitted there were
parties but he hadn't attended any of
them
new york city on high alert coming up
the hunt for the gunman who opened fire
inside a packed subway car
[Music]
after a rush hour shooting in the new
york city subway this morning police are
still searching for the suspect and
asking for the public's help finding him
the gunman they say was a dark-skinned
man wearing a neon construction vest who
opened fire inside a packed subway car
10 people were injured by gunfire
and an additional 13 were either uh
injured as the they rushed to get out of
the train station or they suffered smoke
inhalation witnesses stated
the male opened up two smoke grenades
tossed them on the subway floor
brandishes a glock 9 millimeter handgun
he then fired that weapon at least 33
times striking 10 people
the male then fled the scene
police say none of the injuries are
life-threatening they say they found a
handgun a hatchet fireworks smoke
canisters and gasoline at the scene and
a key to a u-haul which led to someone
they described as a person of interest
they're not calling him a suspect they
are asking the public for cell phone
videos and eyewitness accounts of the
incident
flare airlines has been credited for
putting downward pressure on sky high
ticket prices but as ross lord explains
it could soon be grounded
at a time when the price of just about
everything is going up these air
travelers cherish the low rates offered
by flare airlines it only costed me 89
bucks for me to
get this ticket from vancouver to
montreal
and
yeah i think it's totally worth it if
you are flying domestically it's very
cheap and it's good to fly often but the
airline regulator the canadian
transportation agency says flair may not
be canadian the preliminary decision on
the issue obtained by global news says
there is no evidence currently before
the agency that flair is controlled in
fact by canadians
the regulator says a private investment
firm from miami 777 partners controls
the board of directors provides
financing and supplies aircraft under
lease flair has until may 3 to fix its
arrangement or possibly have its
operating license suspended a
predicament that means uncertainty for
customers very dangerous um high risk uh
and if anybody's you know kind of
risk-averse like i said credit card buy
insurance
and uh make sure you're ready for some
turbulence along the way flair tells
global news it's working with the cta to
resolve the agency's concerns it's also
pleading for an 18-month exemption to
drum up investment from canadian sources
so it can in the words of its
application continue offering low fares
and service to historically underserved
communities for all canadians
this passenger advocate says a temporary
exemption could work in the event that
it goes out of business for any reason
ceased to operate passengers who already
bought tickets
are rebooked on flights of other
airlines at flare's cost in addition to
hundreds of jobs there are millions of
tax dollars on the line flair has
received more than 11 million dollars in
federal grants not a good look now that
the government's airline regulator is on
the verge of shutting it down
transport canada says its minister omar
algabra is assessing flare's bid for
more time
more uncertainty for canadian travelers
looking for affordable and reliable
options ross lore global news windsor
nova scotia
feeling forgotten ahead the afghan
refugees losing hope
countless afghan refugees still face
danger and uncertainty nearly eight
months after fleeing the taliban
takeover of their country canada vowed
to welcome at least forty thousand of
them about ten thousand have arrived in
the country mike derlea reports on those
who are still waiting and losing hope
on a recent day in kabul the taliban
raised its giant flag over a large
gathering of supporters an event
journalist azir khanyad once would have
attended but last august the taliban
made it clear his progressive views on
women's rights and free speech were no
longer welcome in afghanistan the
taliban come out from
armor
to land cruiser and they beat me they
took my phone
and also they took my
cameras and
they beat me on gunpoint
yad escaped to pakistan with his wife
and was invited to apply for
resettlement in canada six months later
their pakistani visas as well as their
savings have run out and their hope is
dwindling abdul rahman is also waiting
for immigration canada to process his
application meanwhile he's now homeless
stateless and broke and his family is
surviving in pakistan on one meal a day
after more than four months
our uh
financial
situation also mentality situation
uh
we are here with
a big depression
dozens of afghan interpreters held a
hunger strike on parliament hill two
weeks ago demanding the government do
more to help those left behind overseas
the federal immigration refugees and
citizenship ministry acknowledges the
process has been slow but maintains the
bottleneck of cases is not canada's
fault citing issues with security
screenings and documentation
and prime minister justin trudeau says
the taliban is throwing up obstacles
the situation over there is challenging
in terms of just getting people out of
afghanistan given uh the way the taliban
is uh preventing and obstructing uh
people fleeing to safety once they're
they're sort of stuck in this
third country or third place you know
they're really at the mercy of
governments
you know wherever
the interpreters global news spoke with
say they feel forgotten they can't go
back to afghanistan they're wearing out
their welcome in pakistan they're past
the point of desperation
microlight global news toronto
next remembering gilbert gottfried's
distinctive voice in comedy
oh oh come right in don't let the fact
that my doors closed dissuade you in any
way from entering my office so he had
the kind of voice that was instantly
recognizable gilbert gottfried has died
he did stand-up comedy for 50 years and
starred alongside eddie murphy and
beverly hills cop too the comedian's
family says he died after a long illness
gottfried brought a number of characters
to life he was the signature voice of
the aflac duck in commercials until he
was fired his humor could sometimes be
crude and often controversial among his
other most recognizable voice roles was
in the 1992 disney movie aladdin
i can't believe it i just don't believe
it we're never gonna get a hold of that
stupid leg just forget it look at this
look at this i'm so ticked off that i'm
multi
gottfried voiced the role of yago the
villainous sidekick parrot in aladdin
today his family asked his fans to
please keep laughing as loud as possible
in gilbert's honor he was 67 years old
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen tonight's your canada
is winnipeg's provoshe bridge before the
storm we'd love to see your canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you